Sport und Bewegung zehn Verben im
Präsens
gehen
ich gehe zum Sport
ich gehe ins Fitnessstudio
ich gehe ins Schwimmbad
gehen
ich gehe
du gehst
er sie es geht
wir gehen
ihr geht sie gehen
machen
ich mache Sport
ich mache Krafttraining
ich mache Yoga
machen ich mache
du machst er sie es macht
wir machen
ihr macht
sie machen
spielen
ich spiele Fußball
ich spiele Golf
ich spiele Basketball
spielen ich spiele
du spielst
er sie es spielt
wir spielen
ihr spielt
sie spielen
fahren
ich fahre fahrrad
ich fahre Skateboard
ich fahre Ski
fahren ich fahre
du fährst
er sie es fährt
wir fahren
ihr fahrt
sie fahren
laufen
ich laufe auf dem Laufband
ich laufe durch den Wald
ich laufe an der Straße entlang
laufen ich laufe du läufst er sie es
läuft
wir laufen
ihr lauft
sie laufen
joggen
ich jogge im Park
ich jogge um den See
ich jogge am Strand
Joggen ich jogge
du zockst
er sie es joggt
wir joggen
ihr joggt
sie joggen
schwimmen
ich schwimme im Schwimmbad
ich schwimme im See
ich schwimme im Meer
schwimmen ich schwimme
du schwimmst
er sie es schwimmt
wir schwimmen
ihr schwimmt
sie schwimmen
springen
ich springe auf dem Trampolin
ich springe Springseil
ich springe ins Wasser
springen ich springe
du springst
er-sie-es
springt
wir springen
ihr springt
sie springen
klettern
ich klettere auf einen Apfelbaum
ich klettere in der Kletterhalle
ich klettere auf einen Berg
klettern
ich klettere
du kletterst
er sie es klettert
wir klettern
ihr klettert
sie klettern
tanzen
ich tanze in der Disco
ich tanze mit Freunden
ich tanze mit meinem partner
tanzen
ich tanze
du kannst
er sie es tanzt
wir tanzen
ihr tanzt
sie tanzen
was machst du gerne für Sport
schreibe es in die Kommentare
hat dir das Video gefallen
dann gib uns einen Daumen hoch
und abonniere unseren Kanal